today's video is probably going to be a
bit of a bummer it happens sometimes I
don't know what the solution to the
problem is
uh but I am
deeply concerned and before we go any
further I want to acknowledge that
everything I'm about to say in this
video is not exclusive to the games
industry it's more exclusive to the
system capitalism but the games industry
is the industry that I love and that I
care about and that I'm passionate about
and then I think about 24 7 and exist in
so that is the center of the
conversation even though I am aware
other Industries deal with the same
issues if you haven't already heard epic
games known for the epic game store and
fortnite and many a very profitable
property has just laid off a significant
number of its Workforce uh including a
lot of people I know who work in game
development and it's been very weird to
watch people at other companies who've
also had layoffs this year be like to
everybody at Epic who got laid off we
have job listings because the truth is
that it is after a number of other
companies have also had layoffs in 2023
which as a reminder is also the year
that has brought us fantastic video
games finally a very good year for video
games and a very bad year for the games
industry and the thing about epic is
they're one of those companies that has
like so much money
that when you even try to rationalize it
it just sounds made up it's like almost
40 billion dollars valuation they are
very significantly owned by tencent
which is one of like the biggest
companies in the world and year over
year their profits increase their
margins increase and yet for some reason
their labor workforce still has to
decrease or so they have said I mean
some of these people who lost their jobs
found out which other colleagues lost
their jobs today in the games industry
because of Twitter like you kind of just
don't know which person of the grab bag
of people that just got laid off is gone
and what kills me about this is that
I've said it so many times on this
channel I know people know it to the
extent that it almost doesn't mean
anything but
game development is really hard we know
guaranteed that a lot of these people
who just got laid off
have given up countless nights and
weekends and taking time away from their
families and not taking trips so that
they could work hard to end up getting
laid off at the end of the day anyway I
feel like that just kills me it's so
hard
to rationalize like how exploitative
these Mega corporations can be with
people's literal lives like you
literally only live once and they will
take everything they possibly can from
you take all of your hours take all of
your energy tell you it's not good
enough and then half the time change the
company directive in two months time so
the thing you are working on that you
were told you had to give a deadline for
when you had to meet the deadline for
doesn't matter in two months anyway and
they completely change their minds or
they'll just lay you off anyway because
the Labor's too expensive regardless of
the fact that they have year-over-year
profits they are a profitable company
they are successful and then the people
who you know work in the games industry
who have all this games industry
experience just have to find the next
company that will do that
just kind of on a cycle over and over
again and the reason I say that it's
unsustainable is that the current growth
model in the games industry is like so
wildly out of hand that I feel like
there has to be a crash AAA games are so
incomprehensibly expensive they also
take a really long time to make we are
at five plus year Game Dev Cycles at
this point for a lot of AAA Studios five
plus years millions and millions and
millions of dollars hundreds and
hundreds if not thousands in some cases
of employees who a lot of whom get hired
as contractors I feel like that's like
such a big problem in the games industry
that I don't know how the media hasn't
tried to cover yet it's very bizarre to
me that there is so much contract work
in the games industry where contracts
just get caught off and these people
aren't earning any Healthcare and it's
also a really bad problem in games
because people are competing with each
other say you have two contract
producers and they know that A Game's
about to ship they're gonna start like
sabotaging each other and competing with
each other in order to try to stay
employed this is a consistent across the
games industry that video game
developments actively hurt by
contractors all these people who should
be employed full-time but aren't and
like when you get to the end of this you
know
five plus year Deb cycle some people
will start leaving because they
recognize they're going to be cutbacks
others get laid off just causing this
like constant anxiety for so many people
who work in this industry who just have
no idea if they'll stay employed and
then as the projects get bigger and more
expensive the impact that has on game
development just becomes bigger and
bigger as well so not only do you have
an industry where you have to have
people who are incredibly skilled at
things that are not that transferable
they also generally have to be pretty
damn passionate especially in the case
of Engineers they could all make way
more money if they didn't work in video
games go work in software engineering
but the point is that they all really
love video games who are just laid off
like it means absolutely nothing
regardless of the time they put in it
can be 10 years in some cases it could
be like a huge chunk of their lives
against so many occasions that these
people these human beings have spent on
working just for a company to lay them
off because it didn't make enough money
it's not like it didn't profit or was it
successful versus the previous year it
just wasn't success full enough versus
the previously like it's it's
unbelievable it's crazy that the system
considers a plateau to be a failure like
oh you're only making 30 billion two
years in a row oh like literally
shareholders will pull out because the
way the whole system functions is they
all just need to make more money all the
time and there's there's certainly so
much money so you just gotta fire people
over and over and over again to give the
Beast what it needs oh but yeah we have
this incredibly long growth cycle now
where it's become doubly unsustainable
because every time you hire somebody new
in game development that cost is like
very high not only is it like high and
that you might have to pay a bonus or
you have to go through the negotiations
it's that you also have to cash somebody
up you can't just join a brand new
studio especially when different Studios
run on different engines you don't know
how far through production a certain
company is there are weeks maybe even a
month where they can't actually really
do any work because you're just paying
them however much you give somebody in a
month to just get caught up and then you
have to do this every time there's
another round of layoffs because the
industry can't sustain itself and
keeping everybody on board even though
again projects are only getting more
expensive and Dev cycles and production
Cycles like the things that would have
happened at Epic not necessarily Dev
just at Epic are just getting bigger and
bigger and longer you're spending more
money you're hiring more people you're
taking more time you're laying off more
people and it's this like vicious cycle
where the solutions are obviously
layoffs or monetization it's monetizing
games it's figuring out how to make FIFA
Ultimate Team for every single game like
honestly FIFA Ultimate Team is like such
a problem in my head because it's like
it makes so much money and is
so renewable you only have to make the
card art for a FIFA Ultimate Team card
once right and you are constantly
already marketing it to the same people
who've already bought FIFA or eafc now
but you get what I mean and every year
it makes so much money and costs
ultimately so little
that it causes every other publisher in
the games industry because of the
literal society that we live in every
publicly traded company that will be
shareholders being like why aren't you
making Ultimate Team money make Ultimate
Team money how haven't you figured out
how to make some infinitely renewable
very easy source of income but we can
repeatedly charge players for something
that is so cost effective and like don't
worry about the game part it's that part
that matters and then Gamers hate that
and so they just get really upset with
the games industry and people talk about
voting with their wallets but the
problem is in my head people do vote
with their wallets people are voting
with their wallets you can talk about
voting with your wallet all you want to
but you're already doing it you talk
about don't pre-order games don't buy a
game if you don't know the quality it's
an insane thing to do and you can have
that conversation as much as you want
but people are still doing it you can
have the conversation about how much you
hit micro transactions or live service
games as much as you want but they still
make so much money like the
conversations are irrelevant the mobile
market in China and Japan is so
appealing to every company on the planet
it makes so much money so vote with your
wallet like yeah people are already
voting with that well it's the wallets
are saying we like my microtransactions
actually you don't have to put as much
time into making that and we will spend
more money on that more of that and the
problem with that is like those
monetization strategies again the ones
that are actually cheaper and thus more
profitable
require less people to make I just feel
like we're in this horrible and
terrifying cycle of um the games
industry is a really scary place to be
for a lot of people because layoffs are
so consistent and you know these people
have lives and jobs and families that
they have to take care of outside of the
hours that they work really hard for
these companies who don't care about
them they get laid off and that saves
the company a little bit of money but
it's still never enough because again
you have to have year over year growth
while you're failing for some reason
just being billion dollar profitable is
not enough profit so then you have to
figure out ways to make money cheaper
follow the trends that work it's just a
cycle that's like squeezing people into
this narrower more terrifying space
where everyone's just trying to exist
and trying to make really fun stuff and
trying to continue to make video games
like of course there are exceptions to
what I'm talking about but this is a
reality for a lot of people and a lot of
people I know have been laid off at some
point like and it's just it just sucks
it's an industry that that so many
people love so much that so many people
are so passionate about and spend so
much time and put so much of themselves
into that I think at this point is like
an untameable Beast like it just I don't
know where it goes from I can make a
video saying support the games you love
anything that you don't like get a
refund for don't just even like review
on it or comment on it that doesn't
matter to capitalism that doesn't matter
to the CEO who's just seeing that they
made a billion dollars you literally
have to ask for refunds you have to take
that money away your tweets don't matter
I promise they don't care negative
YouTube videos that stuff doesn't
actually matter to people making eight
billion dollars a year you have to ask a
refund stop pre-ordering games
legitimately if you love a game buy it
twice or
and I'd love to ask people to do this
but I think that every person would get
corrupted buy stocks in companies that
are doing things you like to try and
reinforce that they're doing things you
like but I really do think that like
very few people would be able to resist
the wait
I dip my toe in this but if I buy stocks
in this one I'll be richer next week
like it's that's I think majority of
humans are just like so susceptible to
that system and this there's just no cap
there's no cat it needs more money it
does not care about the people who care
about it it just it [__] sucks it
really sucks um I'm so sorry to my
friends at Epic who got laid off to
everyone else who's been laid off this
year across the games industry across
games media of course across multiple
Industries I think there are people
being like Oh it means there's a
recession coming it's so weird to see
people be like well they had to have
layoffs because there's you know
Financial downturn which means that
every single one of those people who got
laid off is [__] because of there's a
financial downturn why are you defending
the company and not the people it's
incomprehensible to me yeah I could tell
you the things that I think that would
help but I don't really think they would
help I think it's like unfathomable
amounts of money and and a system that
again requires infinite growth which is
unsustainable and it just I just find it
very scary because the people who are in
the games industry are so
good and care so much and that's so
[__] exploitable this video is
effectively a rant
um it's 4am I can't sleep I just wanted
to say something did I say something I
don't know it just it just sucks it just
really sucks and I don't know when it
ends the companies just make more money
and the rich people just get more
bonuses and everyone else is just trying
to survive or get promoted just for
their boss to hire some dude they worked
with 25 years ago above them anyway and
whenever those people make mistakes the
boss people
no punishment nothing happens
the little guys get laid off I don't
know man it just [__] sucks it just
sucks it sucks